hey guys real quick wanted to just make
a quick one-off video which is something
we have just not been doing quite a bit
of and it's very simple it's this
thought process of you find what you're
looking for I've been giving a lot of
thought to kind of just watching what
I'm seeing out there in the social
digital ecosystem and very honestly just
real life and I'm watching so many
people over the last two to three years
look for negativity look for something
that's wrong
find where people disagree with them
fight look for what was me downside to
half glass empty and and then I go to a
twitter search or look around the world
and I find ridiculously beautiful things
every day every day thousands of kind
acts randomly by people all people that
I have conversations with who see the
opportunities whether it's in business
like voice and AR or crypto or whatever
it may be just this amazingly
interesting thing that I feel the
majority of you are looking for the
wrong while there's plenty of wrong and
plenty of right in the world it comes
down to one very simple thing what are
you choosing to look for because I
promise you if you right now and I'm
making this video for one reason 24
hours of trying to find the good
somebody saves a kitten
somebody opens the door somebody does a
nice thing for you bit somebody says
thank you 24 hours of looking for
positivity could change your life
honestly making us for one [ __ ]
persons one one person watches this
video chooses to do 24 hours of looking
for good instead of looking for bad and
their game changes d-roc heard somebody
at a convenience store saying mom you're
always so negative you're always so
negative I am blown away by the fact
that life gets real simple if you break
down into this are you looking for the
negative this sucks this government
sucks this person sucks this is [ __ ] or
you're looking for the positive she's
nice that's remarkable I've got this
opportunity you choose what you're
looking for because what you look for
you find that's how [ __ ] life works